since 1976 the Netherlands has been
world famous for its lacks drug laws and
pot cafes in 1996 the US state of
California legalized marijuana for
medical purposes doctors prescriptions
are easy to come by making lead almost
as culturally accepted as alcohol in
2001 both Canada and Portugal relaxed
their drug laws Canada legalized medical
marijuana use and Portugal stop
prosecuting users in 2013 Uruguay
stepped it up a notch becoming the first
country in the world to fully legalize
in order to regulate the marijuana trade
now several countries in Latin America
are getting in on the debate back in the
US on January 1st 2014 people in
Colorado braved snow and ice to buy
their first legal recreational stash of
ganja On January 8th New York became the
21st US state to legalize medical
marijuana and July 8th Washington State
became the second state in America to
legalize recreational pot Alaska and
Oregon may be next to follow but it
still may be a long time until marijuana
activists see the rest of the world's
drug laws go up in smoke